Maybe from your perspective,
because you run such an
organization and a Vlad,
the CEO of Robin hood sort of had to make decisions really quickly,
probably had to wake up in the middle of the night kind of thing. Uh, you know,
and he also had a conversation with Elon Musk on, uh, clubhouse,
which I just signed up for. It was, it was a fascinating,
one of the great journalistic, uh, performances of our time.
The most surprise for you, Larry is would it be, if he gets an
a and then his Wikipedia.
It'd be like journalist and a.
Part-time entrepreneurs, this magnets business, as you know,
I don't know if you can comment on.
Any aspects of that, but like, if you were a Vlad,
how would you do things differently?
What are your thoughts about his interaction with Elan,
how he should have played it differently? Like,
I guess there's a lot of aspects of this interaction. One is about transparency.
Like how,
how much do you want to tell people about really what went down there's NDAs
potentially involved, uh, how much on,
in private do you want to push back and say, no,
you to centralize power, whatever the phone calls you're getting,
which I'm sure he was getting some kind of phone calls that might not be
contractual. Like it's not contracts that are forcing him, but he was being,
uh, what do you call it?
Like pressured to behave in certain kinds of ways from all kinds of directions?
Like what, uh, what do you take from, uh, this whole situation?
I was very excited to see flood response. I mean,
it's pretty cool to have him talk to Elan. Right.
And one of the things that like struck me in the first,
like few seconds I've led speaking was like, I was like,
is Vlad like a boomer? Like, like,
like he seemed like a 55 year old man talking to a 20 year old
Ilan was like the 20 year old. And he's like the 55 year old man.
You can see why Citadel are NMR buddies. Right? Like you can,
you can see why it's like, this is a, this is a nice, it's not a bad thing.
It's like, he's, it's like, he's got a good respectable professional attitude.
Boy.
He also tried to do like a jokey thing. Like, no,
we're not being ageist here, boomer. Uh, but like, like a,
like a 60 year old CEO of bank of America would try to make a joke for the kids.
That's what [inaudible].
Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. I was like, what is this? This guy's like, what is he 30?
Uh, and I'm like, this is weird. Yeah. Um,
but I think maybe that's also what I like about Elan's kind of influence on
American business is like, he's super like anti they're professional, right?
Like why, why say, why say, you know,
a hundred words about nothing. Right.
And so I liked how he was cutting in and saying flat,
what do you mean the beans, bro?
Yeah. So you, you don't have to be courteous.
It's like the first principles thinking it's like, what the hell happened?
And let's just talk like normal people. The problem of course is,
uh, you know, for Ilan, uh, it's cost them. What is it?
Tens of millions of dollars is tweeting like that. But perhaps it's a war,
the price to pay because ultimately there's something magical about
just being real and honest and just going off the cuff and making the
mistakes and paying for them, but just being real and then moments like this,
that was an opportunity for Vlad to be that. And he felt like he wasn't. Um,
do you think there,
do you think we'll ever find out what really went down?
If there was something shady underneath it all?
Yeah. I mean, it would be sad if nothing shady happened. Right.
But his presence made it shade.
Sometimes I feel like that would Mark Zuckerberg,
the CEO of Facebook. Sometimes I feel like, yeah,
there's a lot of things that Facebook is doing,
but sometimes I think he makes it look worse by the way he presents himself
about those things. Like,
I honestly think that a large amount of people at Facebook just have a
huge unstable, chaotic system and they're all,
not all, but a mass or trying to do good with this chaotic system.
But the presentation is like, it sounds like there's a lot of, uh,
back room conversations that are trying to manipulate people. Uh, and there's,
there's something about the realness that Elon has that it feels like CEO's
should have had that opportunity.
I think Mark's like Barry had that too, when he was younger, younger,
and somebody said, you gotta be more professional, man. You can't say, you know,
law to an interview. Uh,
and then suddenly he became like this distance person that was hot. I'd like,
you'd rather have him make mistakes,
but be honest than be like professional and never make mistakes.
Yeah.
One of the difficult hires I think is like marketing
people or like PR people is you have to hire people that get the fact that
you can say law on an interview, or I,
you know,
take risks as opposed to what the PR I thought to quite a
few big CEOs and the people around
them are trying to constantly minimize the risk of like, what did he say?
The wrong thing? What does she says the wrong thing? It's like,
what the be careful it's constantly like, Ooh, like, I don't know.
And there's this nervous energy that builds up over time with larger,
larger teams where the whole thing, like I visited YouTube, for example,
everybody had talked YouTube, incredible engineering and incredible system,
but everybody's scared. Like, let's be, uh,
let's be honest about this like madness that we have going on of huge
amounts of video that we can't possibly ever handle.
There's a bunch of hate on YouTube. There's this chaos of comments,
bunch of conspiracy theories, some of which might be true.
And then just like this mess that we're dealing with,
and it's exciting as beautiful. Uh,
it's a place where like democratizes education, all that kind of stuff.
And instead they're all like sitting in like VR trying to be very polite and
saying like, well, we're just a one to improve the health of our platforms.
Like, all right, man, let's just be real. Let's,
let's, let's both advertise how amazing this fricking thing is.
But also to say like, we don't know what we're doing.
We have all these Nazis posting videos on YouTube. We don't,
we don't know how to like handle it and just being real like that.
I suppose that's just a skill. Um, maybe it can't be taught, but over time,
the, whatever the dynamics of the company is,
it does seem like Zuckerberg and all this get worn down. They just get tired.
They get tired of not being real of not being real, which is a sad.